ist auch der tag an dem der tv spot in
den fernsehsendern erscheint auf ich
glaube allen anderen wandten sendepause
skills und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge quick survival games und wir
spielen heute welchen spielmodus können
wir spielen
moment mal habe ich vielleicht eben
schon gespeichert ich glaube schon okay
da ist mein gehirn ist schon wieder
krank und jemand was will stürmischen
feiern in bamberg ist wie es keine kiste
jetzt ein bisschen struggle wärme nein
ok kommen vielleicht spam wäre etwas
ganz neues ist dass wir da was einst als
dankeschön junge ja ja ja das alter was
war das gerade alter schwede sie jetzt
erst mal kurz durch sortieren die egal
wie geil glück ab dass sie nicht sein
staff aufgesammelt hat oder passen sie
möglichst kühlen sie egal auf wen er war
auch sauer hat den stoff nicht auf
gesammelt das ist alles was zählt gerade
und da ist nämlich von der nächste level
auch bisschen was oder elektra bisschen
schade oder leg mich ein bisschen
electric sehr ziemlich sehr sogar
ziemlich steigt nämlich sehr wohl kann
moment mal die leggins habe ich kann
mich nicht mit leggins angezogen haben
wie dieser runde gut
warum muss jetzt sicherlich wo um oder
er uns weil er uns mit dem alter schwede
das war knapp sourcag leute ich weiß
nicht wie es mit der es regeln kurs gs
schreibt meine kommentare was ihr davon
haltet normalerweise besagt die es regel
ja dass man zur nachrüstung immer nch
einem treiben muss aber jetzt gibt es im
kurs gegen shane helme gibt es leider
nicht deswegen würde mich mal
interessieren dass wir ab das thema
abstimmen was meint ihr
cts regel auch ein kurs gehe ich spiele
immer holz so als würde sie nicht zählen
oder als würde sie zu ja ich will mal so
als würde sie zählen einfach mal hin zu
gehen dass ich nicht mit liegestützen
nach und muss hallo sage schlicht und
einfach mental haustüren laufen um auch
einen schweizer pass hat muss man die
kommentare erzählt die es regel auch im
kurs gehe oder nicht
darf man außerdem machen von der s regel
oder nicht eigentlich darf man es nicht
also prinzipiell würde ich sagen das ist
so eine wichtige sache diese regel da
darf man keine ausnahme machen
aber andererseits und rrr es ist jetzt
auch gar kein problem
ich meine es ist halt auch unmöglich im
kurs gds regel zu machen
das heißt man müsste sich in jeder runde
einfach liegestützen empfangen wenn man
seine kunden voll ausschöpfen will
hey was geht oder hat den als schwächer
aber größte ego lucky das handy in die
lava geflogen ist lucky fokker aber ich
auch lakic und jetzt in der luft die
combo jetzt geht's ab bitkom befragt
doch die apes wo es langgeht oder tnt
aber dann können wir auch ausweichen hat
max ich frage mich immer was es bringt
dieses wort und chat zu schreiben wo ich
mach das auch
aber irgendwie ich weiß auch nicht wo es
gab wohl hacks bestehen und er brennt
jetzt wenigstens session
die tankstelle ist doch wunderbar ja
hacker bekommen es jetzt schreiben jetzt
entweder lief die runde oder papa
klassiker okay ich würde sagen wir
sprechen dann meinen die nächste rolle
aber irgendwie will man youtube ist
heckmann ich keine ahnung dass irgend so
eine regel so leute wunder nummer zwei
und versuchen wieder unser glück hallo
frist für das christkind man dann hätte
ich gerne dankeschön
dabei ist er mir glaub ich ein oder oder
später die durch julian schieber
holzschwert in es mein lieber so sehr
schön
damit ist immer da allein für den namen
muss man schon wieder so nah ist schon
viele pfeile gut
das habe hier noch ein lanes nehme ich
mit und ja auch gut können wir auch
mitnehmen
wir dürfen jetzt aber keine eigens dazu
anziehen denn es regelt ist schon
bescheid und so weiter und so fort
ich habe übrigens kein team die lösung
dazu gefunden die lösung ist einfach
wenn man jetzt werdet ihr euch mal mache
ich den clean up king wenn es wenn man
eine die az hat ist jetzt natürlich
keine volle leistung mehr sondern eben
alben plus die ja und dann gilt auch die
es regel nicht mehr denn die gilt nur
für vollere dankeschön team hatte
dann so freut sich der mast schöner
abgang
und noch einer genau
und er ist immer da warum jetzt kann der
andere ich von der seite bitte weg spam
nein gerade jetzt gehen wir die pfeile
aus lucky you lucky lakic leben der noch
hat auch kurz den absprung nicht
verpassen
nicht so nice es aber den sack zack zack
zack zack zack da ist es schon gut weil
ich mir sagen lassen meint noch eine
partie wieder ins wasser aber jetzt nein
er hat noch einen wegstecken
die eg kann auch ein weg stecken lässt
sich dauern an
jetzt ist er da sehr schön gut wir
stecken noch ein paar pfeile von mir
oder von irgendwem der gerade in dieser
branche morgi beteiligt war war aber gut
so machen es aber glaube ich so so
vernehmlich weniger offene es gibt
keinen leder passieren dass hat man
meist automatisch ein rüstungs punkt weg
nicht so gut aber es alles easy würde
ich mal sagen na wie sieht's aus zwei
leute noch laser ente aus dem clan dax
diesmal war endlich mal ein witziger
klaren ja auch ganz gut passt und auch
irgendein anderer auto nice bei der
diashow ok problem denke ich jetzt auch
okay la petite sich kurz eine tpg
schießt mal den five nicht egal ich bin
voll gefährlich an haben hier jetzt
alter verwaltet alle haben sich hier
versammelt richtige rest über werte in
diesen diesen deathmatch allerwiesen
balljungen guck mal die schießt ihre
vereine hin und her und ich lauf
dazwischen jungen cleanup ich habe etwas
schlecht widmen ich bin clean abdeckt
hallo hallo geführt wird auch yahoo
sorry for clean up schreibe ich mal
einen gedanken hinspiel verlassen alles
klar nicht weinen wird sagte springt mal
in die nächste runde drei leute und wir
sind endlich mal auf einer map die nicht
ganz so eng und so hektisch ist dahin
war einfach keine kiste kann es sein
kann es sein dass wirklich als porno ne
kiste ist hier auch geil da war die
konnte ich nicht sehen vor allem
standpunkt aus so eine waffe
du hast keine vorhersagen was sehr schön
den helm das einfach mal liegen denn ich
will den mit dinge mitnehmen fängt sich
aber ich bin es da einiges an stoff
alter
warum zieht er das nicht an da muss es
doch in rodgau gehabt haben okay aber
ist nicht mein ding ich jetzt in diesem
punkt nicht mein ding ich darf dann auch
trotzdem mitnehmen
zack zack zack der ist auch weg und der
hier wie viel frisst der der frist
nichts gehört
er gibt mir einfach aus dem stand eine
zweier combo das muss man auch was man
kann
das ist einfach zurücklassen ich glaube
der lebt unter der erde da sieht der nie
so ne es so nur vor allen dingen sonne
er sieht die sonne rapture ist schon
recht ihres stands der läuft ja ich war
noch nie auf dem fenstersims hier oben
stehen geblieben dann weiter gewachsen
holen denkt schon jetzt genau jetzt mit
der clique und einen noch sehr schön und
der nächste kasper webmail wo ich muss
sagen caspers endlich ganz ganz ganz
nahe sein name und sack
es ist witzig wie alle leute eigentlich
immer dasselbe muster laufen so jetzt
können wir nämlich auf die tierschutz
anziehen und unsere an unserer almut das
waren zuvor nicht gestattet frisch frech
frisch mainz orchester so jetzt chillen
am pool live videochat wir haben ein
bogen genug feinde kannst du dir
anpacken eigentlich geniale
voraussetzung für das kommende death
match gegen den einzigen gegner dennoch
auf der karte ist ein kleines feuer der
firma okay das soll ich auch nicht nein
sei es gucken was wir können
ach ja leute ich wollte euch ich wollte
euch in diesem video was zum essen soll
es erzählen denn es ist jetzt weile her
dass er das letzte mal von mir und dem
essen soll das gehört habe vielleicht
forschen preisgeben kann ich auf der web
auf der webpage auf der map wünschen ein
junger lucky you älter der hat so halt
gefressen
man sah keinen fall keinen fall keinen
fall doch noch weil ja frist eine feile
noch pfeil noch fall sehr schön
man muss ein bisschen vor erhalten ich
kann aber ich habe gefühlt die bisschen
die kontrolle über den bus verloren so
aber jetzt leute noch infos zum essen
soll das was ich noch sagen wollte
bevor ich jetzt lang drumrumreden damals
gespielt das kann er was erzählen
das funktioniert so 16 trifft da kommt
der erste satz in die läden sechzehnter
siebter ist auch der tag an dem der tv
spot in den fernsehsendern erscheint auf
ich glaube allen anderen wandten sendern
also rtl natürlich sehr relevant
tatsächlich aber wie gesagt das würde
auf relevanten sendern erscheinen dann
sagen sie rtl.de aber auch rtl vox
prosieben wahrscheinlich seit 1 also ihr
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich zu sehen
bekommen welche den zu sehen bekommt
schreibt mir sehr gerne mal irgendwie
auf twitter und markiert mich da das
echt witzig das habe ich schon bei wenig
gesehen hat ja auch mal so ein telekom
spot nee du gehst du bist an alle nennen
sich freund in letzter zeit entweder
viele nennen sich freund in letzter zeit
also xy freund oder aber ich sehe immer
nur die gleiche person vor allem auch
gut eingesetzt von ihm macht es nicht
schlecht er macht es echt nicht schlecht
hier kannst nicht bewusst ist kein ding
ich laufe einfach so weit dass mich
weiter brüssel kannst hast da kommt
nämlich leute oder kurz matthias feld
wird im mai ist der star ist wiederum
was gibt sozusagen 16 ich habe für sechs
tage kommt der tv spot rein also wenn
ihr den sehen wollt dann zwischen dem
sechsten 16 22 mal einschalten
das fernsehen dass wir eigentlich alle
gar nicht mehr benutzen ich glaube ich
echt viele benutzer nicht macht kommt es
hier noch mal ein und früher ist doch
mal eine million frühere nummer 1
und jetzt fertig ist für sich dankeschön
aber mein körper okay ist
natürlich aber gut leute man kann nicht
jede runde gewinnen das war es von heute
wenn ihr noch irgendwelche fragen
weshalb sie gerne in die kommentare
wir sehen zum nächsten video wieder haut
rein und auch was ich noch sagen wollte
leute es gibt noch ein zwei online
votings auf dem weg zum ersten platz im
burger battle
da kann man mal richtig gas geben glaube
ich ab dem 16 startet das online voting
auch für die fürs halbfinale
und da kommt aus final aber dazu später
infos zu einem später zeit und wir sehen
uns wieder haut rein machst gut und